okay I cheese earlier that it is not
just Democrats now calling for the
recusal a resignation as chair of the
House investigation into the Trump
Russia scandal it has been really just
Democrats until now now we have a
Republican the first Republican adding
his name to the list of people saying
that Devin Nunez should not be leading
this house intelligence committee
investigation into potential collusion
between Donald Trump and Russia I am
talking about none other than
congressman Walter Jones a Republican
from North Carolina who said to the hill
yesterday that absolutely Devin Nunez
should recuse himself from that
investigation here is a quote from
Walter Jones how can you be chairman of
a major committee and do all these
things behind the scenes and keep your
credibility you can't keep your
credibility if anything has shown that
we need a commission this has done it by
the way he has acted that's the only way
you can bring integrity to the process
the integrity of the committee looking
into this has been tainted yes Speaker
Paul Ryan signaled that he's standing
behind Devin Nunez don't worry Paul Ryan
is dead Paul Ryan is the type of scumbag
who will save this for now but if Nunez
ends up recusing himself Ryan will come
up with something totally meaningless
like I know Devin Nunez he's a good man
a family man I respect his decision I
still believe in him but I am respectful
of the decision that he has made you
know it'll be that type of thing if
Devin Nunez ultimately resigns Paul Ryan
will be asked about it he'll say
something like that well it's no
surprise that Paul Ryan is being loyal
to his own party rather than own up to
what the truth is yeah and yeah do you
believe that at this point Paul Ryan
knows what the real truth is here like
if your speaker of the house someone
must come to you if it's abundantly
clear that the more investigation that's
done in to trump rush of the worst the
evidence looks somebody must have come
to Paul Ryan and said listen Pali boy
it's bad if we really do a fair
investigation it's going to become
public that it's really really bad he
has to know perhaps I remember Devon
Nunez before he
went to the White House to tell them
about the revelations he found yeah he
went to the speaker first did he yeah
interesting I encourage our audience to
contact Walter Jones and thank him for
being objective about this you can go to
Jones house gov you can tweet him at rep
Walter Jones you can call 20 22 25 3415
Nunez needs to resign he must recuse
himself and I think that if we make it I
don't know if I want to say more
palatable but if we make it seem more
mainstream for Republicans to demand the
same thing maybe you will get more
Republicans pushing for that recusal
which would probably be useful at this
point and Walter Jones represents North
Carolina which is of course a swing
state I think that's where it would
start the more moderate Republican yeah
maybe in fear of losing a future
re-election battle also one more note
about the hold of a new nest thing
remember that whole thing about how
Nunez got that intelligence that Trump
team members were incidentally
surveilled during surveillance of
foreign targets Devon nuñez has now
straight up said that he's never going
to reveal where he got that information
and there's different speculation that
he get it from a a trump insider did he
get it from someone else from the
executive branch because we know he
visited the White House and now we
actually have a transcript of a
conversation where a reporter said to
Devon nuñez will you share your source
reveal your source to other members of
the committee and Devon una said we will
never reveal sources and methods to
which the reporter followed up and said
even two other members of the committee
and nuñez said nope never we're talking
about the bottom of the barrel here he
won't share the Intel with other people
involved in the investigation yes Evan
unos is a really dumb guy especially cuz
now we know what to look into where did
he get these sources from actually feel
duped I wanted to give devan une as a
chance and act like I would assume he
would do this or rather not act like but
I assumed until proven otherwise that
Devon Nunez could conduct this
investigation fairly and objectively I
watched some of his early press
conferences when he was put in charge of
this and he struck me as a guy who is
going to consider all that
and he's not going to hide anything and
he's not going to be loyal to Donald
Trump in this entire thing and I feel
duped and keeping nunez on makes no
sense for Republicans either because now
that he has clearly been compromised as
a puppet of Trump if the house
investigation ends up saying hey nothing
to see here Trump is cleared Democrats
obviously we'll call it out as a
completely partisan and untrustworthy
investigation it's almost if you believe
there's really nothing to see between
Trump and Russia it's in the interests
of Republicans to get nunez off so that
it's not as easy to write off the entire
thing as partisan hackery yeah we can
only hope that we can still trust
Richard burr who is the chairman of the
Senate Intelligence Committee george w
bush said that he is confident that
Richard burr is going to be able to
carry out the investigation fairly I
don't know I don't necessarily go to
george w bush for who is trustworthy and
who isn't i don't really trust what he's
confident about honestly yeah send me
your thoughts about this i'm on twitter
at d pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show fantastic program for
you today